パターフェースカーフ攻撃
はいこれは誰です
はっはっは
4000個の間の場合になるかっ
予選かける音で初なんです
マッハんいかん
ん
攻め込まれてくださいなんでわかってるんですけど
ブーブー
みんなで81からは言いたいなまぁ全然ないもう来たら来たで撮るんだけどまぁいっ
ちゃ寝させ
かなりちょっと急いでたからその後彼らは
我々を盗撮したと
tue
te
bea
me
暴力だろう動い倉ダムでまぁ結局将生と皆さんの撮影したかったんだけども
彼らがその湿った到達したしても討伐時代だめだよ盗撮自体ダメなんだけどその
ちょっと写真をツイッターでつぶやきました
結構いろんな人が見ちゃってここにいますねそうはじめんが母にたよみたいな潰れ
ちゃってそれを見って結構
人が来ました何人くらい10人以上がちょっと人がきちゃって
まぁ結局その日は残念ながら撮影を中断します
なんかこうさは分かる俺のことを
写真なんか写真いいですかみたいな一言言ってくれれば全然そのせいかさーん
こっちローターさんの撮影ないでさぁマジな顔で偽持つとか本気で波紋出るとかを取ら
れたらやっぱ嫌な書けよ
二ナンデ勘手にとって勝手にツイッターにあげちゃうけ
そうなぞ
いやあああちょっと脾臓にね悲しいというか全然あの外で見かけて声にかけてくれたで
はいいんですよ写真入れシカって言ったらモチロンぜ取りますし
磯じゃない時はね例えば取りますし全然かいいんですけどその
盗撮はまずだめだすめちゃくちゃ嫌な気持ちになるして犯罪にもなるし
マジでそれをつぶやいちゃうとみんな喫煙だけよパッチ話なんでここがあって結局来て
ねなんか大ごとになったから馬崎トレは結構今積もってたんですけど
数井で多いとリティで逃げましたとという感じで今日一日は年間を盗撮されてたくさん
の人に追われてやりたいこともできずに
なんとか公安隊つですね
すぐに彼のシート割れねじゃあまずねランド何が言いたいかといいますと
とりあえず我々もう人間ですから
盗撮はダメで本当に俺たちに限ったことじゃないよ
そうそうそう全然も何か他の人もそうだし電車内とかでもそうだして知らないととか
でかくていいとリムはダメなことです友達とかをプレイ
7もういいと思うんですけどそこはちょっと違うなと思います非常に我々嫌な気もつを
しております
嫌なことしてるよしかもそれが音何回もやられるからねぇ
朝枚分はなく
プラーズ理由を言ってないから待ってね動画の方にも影響してちゃう
えほんとそうだよなぜねどうなるかというの分かってくるじゃんそれはもう本見た彼は
悪くない相続でた分かり俺をなんてそんなのあるでだって編み違いますと言われ酒造が
言いますてる撮ら俺あそこに走っていくかもしれませんそこをちょっとさせて欲しかっ
たなっていう感じでございますねもう来てくださったことは全然いいなんか会いたいと
思ってくれた時嬉しいんですけど
未来チャートみんなきちゃうからまあそもそも盗撮はダメだよっていう話を今日はし
なかったですね
うれしいことだけどさなんか中で大変や
救っシャー
悔しいね
pc と思ってる見てくれてる人が増えてかなりづらくな何たところ結構あるからそこ
はなんとか我々でうまいことやっていかなきゃいけないんですけどそれでもやっぱ
どうしようがないことがあるって目覚める協力がないとできないかなって思ってるんで
もしでその撮影してるときに見かけて何かやってるなって思ってもまあね写真とか
取らないで欲しいなっていうことを言いたいこういうことがまた起きると我々はもっと
外に出なくなりますが悲しいよ
怒ってるもグレーブルー思ってるんだよってかまーすぺ経た人もチェック滑ってパンっ
てくださって枯れてるんちゃうかなー確かネットにえっにらずってことは結局みんな
たら何言われても仕方ないとこがあるんで
それでもいいならで厚別ダメだダメだよダメでつべちゃダメだったら潰れちゃうと結局
ねみちゃん人も起こるからよくないしては本当に入っただねやっぱその取った子達も
悪い気がなかったかもしれないって
今後きょうつけましょうという話通されたぞ
あるしなんか俺に似てる人がいたと言ってその人も勝手に盗撮されててかわいそうだっ
た
だだめではまあ山々ネットのまだ買ってないそれじゃあねどうこの現在は生きて来ない
よ
てかさわかるよねまずカメラ向けてたらすごいわかりますがソースは明らかに好転か
みんな本当ほとんどここでまずは本当にわかりやすいよ
前で取りますけどおりますけれどもせめて一声かけていただきたいこっちにもタイミン
グっていうのは彼
告白みたいな心10個の準備ができて怖かったね
語録にねはいなんかてつらポットからこうやってカメラをつけてるんだよ強風ですよね
怖かったよ
今回ちょっと久しぶりにものもつかずになってしまったんですが
一夏俺の動画を見ている奴らだけでも心よ
俺の動画を見てる奴らだけでも心得ておいてくれ盗撮は犯罪です
で鮮烈は超築きましょう映画館は静かに今ぐらいですかね
とりあえずネットのまだはきょうつけて守っていきましょうぞ今日は区別かったです
こんな感じではある
悲しくにペンませ狂ってみてゆんだよねっ
受けレギュラー子連れ外れ絶対ファーめっちゃくちゃさあ誇張2しかうわーっ
マネして真似して1回だけだよね本当に猿の真似するだけでからっていきます
th
def